welcome to shiver shiver is a game it
takes place in the cold and that's
literally all I know about it but what
more do you need for a horror game the
retirement community is still a few
hours away I hope dad isn't too lonely
there I said I'm having a really hard
time keeping my eyes on the road I've
been driving for hours
Wow that's not a good sign and you
should probably maybe pull over and
sleep a cigarette would help right now
oh yeah let me just reach on over here I
really need to smoke first all right
gah Fred's just what I need I'm so cool
with my lung cancer I really need to
smoke first well I'm trying oh is this
one of those old school cars with a
cigarette lighter in there you bet there
aren't any radio stations out here where
did you put your dad why is your dad in
a retirement home where in the boonies
where you live
honk honk no cops to be found out here
you know Harmons speeding a bit Hey
aah do I in Midori Oh put that bad boy
oh I see blam got it
I've told Dad I'd quit but smoking
really clears my mind another one
couldn't hurt I'm good for now what I
really want smooth okay all right what
do we got
Oh Cooper no whoa 50% off your bag of
new whoa 1990 interested cool tape my
road mixtape keeps me company on the
road okay slam it in this shape is
wicked recorded straight from FM oh I
forgot yeah that was a thing you could
sit for I can't believe we forgot that
that was a thing oh hell yeah
now we're talking when you listen to
music you're never really alone yeah
true words shoo what
well was that shiver um shiver me
timbers why is that on the road hello
look at that I'm dead oh wait no I'm not
dead I think my arm is broken
all right well that's not good at least
I'm not alone I got my music hey a rock
I'll never be alone again ah for some
reason I expected the immaturity yeah
yeah okay I get it
[ __ ] get out here where's my mixtape
all right I'm Audi hey my arm is
definitely broken I need to get help
a blizzard is rolling in and expected to
hit on Tuesday the 13th authorities
advise individuals to remain indoors and
under no circumstance attempt to drive
that's awfully convenient unsaid it's
2020 yeah well my car's a wreck I'm
lucky I even survived the crash I didn't
know this was gonna be a point-and-click
adventure game I like it
these trees must have slowed my fall or
broken your arm one or the other I guess
all right I don't think I'm gonna have
to worry about that poison ivy in this
weather
Oh shooty Tootie this way please Oh
what do we have here getting lost
doesn't seem likely if I stay on the
paths old food wrappers in general
garbage don't forget check out mort's
mind go to the visitors center for
details about tours first and solid no
one is gonna be writing this anytime
soon I don't know if that's how bikes
work I think he just kind of like start
pedaling and it'll yeah whatever
it's exactly like you would expect out
here what I'll save Haven look it's a
little stinky but it's gonna keep you
alive ooh pretty though okay that's
where I creamed off a loose patch of
snow dad and I would use these to hold
our beer cans yeah yeah beautiful if a
little eerie oh come on
don't be such a baby let's smoke it's
cold out I need shelter and help
okay this guardrail really could have
tried harder yeah also what about that
thing that I saw in the middle of the
road
hey listen can you bring up a flashback
of that moment yeah that thing um I just
remembered that that's a that was
probably a monster and I'm in the woods
with it alone yeah I just remembered
that that's probably fun windy oak
National Park yeah let's go in why not
hey what's deal a globe but something
caught in the tree I can't quite reach
it
grand opening all right until further
notice for concerns and questions please
contact Ray Holden provincial parks
Minister signed ray Holden okay
heavy-duty Locke not a welcoming sight
balloons are pretty sad too filthy and
empty inside I can relate I think we all
can anyway moving on window I can see
inside through the glass where's my rock
yeah I guess I don't have it
hatchet thank you I feel better with
this hatchet in hand Oh
ooh rubber hose generator it's out of
gas it's not a gas just dump gas into
Roy here
property of lupus and associates
birthday magician to generate a rental
la a bean uh mhm I thought it was gonna
be some like acronym alright fine then
fine if that's how you're gonna be let
me try to hatch it this bad boy lock is
much too thick to cut through how about
the wind ooh it's useless as a shelter
if I smash open the window well okay
you're right about that listen I just
got an idea you just need to let me be
doors locked
oh okay nervous Wade we're way will whoa
hello whoa open up alright there's
something weird about that okay rotten
from the inside well how about I smash
it it oh yeah wow this won't this a
couple of swings with my good arm did
the trick by big beefy good arm not I
like my stupid old arm it's an old scrap
of coat I found a key in the pocket
while thou sure convenient to have up in
the trees had this jacket get torn apart
and
it's not ask too many questions I guess
can I have it oh I got the key okay
let's try this key oh yes that did the
trick I should be able to get inside now
all right it's Prabhu it's just as cold
in here is out there I need to get the
heater running okay Josh I need you to
call me as soon as you find this note I
don't know what kind of prank you're
trying to pull but you can't just
disappear with two guests in the mine
the police have been contacted and they
want to start a proper investigation
when the storm dies down there's a very
serious situation so please contact me
at once and I'll be over to sort
everything out and call me using the
radio in the back room I know you have
Samantha's car to get in when you do
that I'll be over within minutes
ridiculous
kidnapping prank of yours you silly
Billy
can't believe you i wildlife warning
when do national parks stay safe do not
feed the animals it's like guess that
Pokemon but I can't do it cuz my brains
too small they can feed themselves lazy
fast it's Park Watchtower callsigns
windy oak National Park Beaver Valley
National Park McDonald Watchtower gray
wolf tepee glowing eagle Sun Valley okay
so that's probably important for when I
get to the radio but I doubt I need to
memorize that Latvian Soviet Socialist
Republic 193 proof vodka
looks like someone needed to loosen up
looks like someone needed to die but
that's Everclear Jerry's alright I'd
rather avoid this for now I heard they
can give you cancer cancer or whatever a
classic yet radical approach to the
rectangle all off-brand snacks well how
about I get some kaboom I don't really
want the snacks that badly what you need
your energy nothing but it never hurts
to check for loose change
alright fine then jeez they must have
gotten used to it it's seen better days
how about we smash it okay that didn't
seem to work alright whatever you're an
idiot you doesn't seem to work okay
Ranger staff only
okay so there's someone has a card
reader somewhere in this
[Applause]
do you want to run that by me again
how did that happen is someone there
okay Oh personal photos I'll make work
feel like home yeah whatever shut up I'm
gonna go outside hey my rock I think
this is the rock from the car can I have
it
okay only moderately concerning only one
set of footprints - so that's a little
strange looks like someone's trying to
dilute me okay wait whoa what what back
up hi hi vagina all right great
the faint rancid breeze blows from the
great it's an old oak tree the only one
I've seen so far about we had [ __ ] it
tree is way too thick I think it would
take forever to cut down hey
vodka could be used as gasoline I mean
it's pretty much all doc all that could
burn maybe I don't know okay hey whoa
it's beautiful so he's beautiful hey
Morty in the mine haha watch your head
watch your head you got tell me where
those two people Lexie and bring up an
image of that old mobster that I ran
away from okay did it look like mourning
the mine Mort Mort did it look like Mort
here ah no okay I guess it didn't okay
goodbye ooh al sorry to let you know
like this but I'm done I'm going home
not coming back okay Mikey Court is Josh
to look after I can't keep going into
that mind it's seriously freaking me out
the darkness it sounds honestly make me
wonder if something's down there that
combined with all the stories Josh keeps
telling me about the miners that were
never found during the sinkhole disaster
is more than I can handle
so here's my notice of resignation
Samantha lantern and empty lantern I
wonder if I can find some feel for it
alcohol waste of vodka but it should be
do it should do the trick
okay nice and bright oh good I did it
I'm so smart guys I did it it's pretty
good
okay so I gotta get this thing powered
somehow which means that I gotta look
for a way that's something with this
grate and I mean maybe the generator
here connects up with everything else
but I I haven't been able to power it
yet so we got to find some way to do
that maybe something up here that I
overlooked
maybe back at the car wait yes the gas
tank of course rubber hose shady gas
tank it's shady need a container well I
got an empty new Oh tasting burns like
gasoline but hey I play these types of
games before I've done this once or
twice alright this probably won't run
long just need to start it it didn't
start I might have to try a few times
okay did you narrator start it I should
get inside and see if I can contact help
somehow I don't have the key card to get
it looks like there might be already
behind that door I wonder if I can get
in I just need a key card okay so I need
to get a key card that's what I thought
so if I can just go get a key card
probably swoo hey we got power flickery
borer like power but we've got power
I don't like the way that door was
indecisive and anxious that door is a
mood oh this is not good I don't like
the look I don't like this
[Music]
also what is it what was that
oh okay I guess there was nothing then I
guess it was just my imagine was this
something sad Oh moving in the darkness
there okay it's broken is there any
other way out I'm probably not one oh
it's my mouse cuz I got a landlord bring
up that picture again it's my face on it
okay whatever we're going hey beer can
your bottom extra dark think I can find
a place to recycle this at least you're
environmentally conscious you got all
the right priorities my dude looks like
they're turning this into a tourist
attraction maybe not some pretty heavy
construction underway okay
hi creepy little Mole yeah a little bit
the Bleak flats mine bleak flats mine
was closed in 1948 following a
disastrous mine collapse prompted by the
unexpected opening of an enormous
sinkhole with a balloon yeah run
tourists into there with a sinkhole
miners and equipment alike were
swallowed by the earth leading to a
multi-day rescue operation only three of
the two dozen missing miners were
recovered alive great the Bleak flats
collapse led to a strike and then the
combined cost caused the mind to
formally shut down just three months
later in March of 30 1949 the land on
which the mine sits has been bought and
sold several times until generously
donated by Sam stone Mining Corporation
for use as a National Park great did you
know the rust on the old tools form
through a process called oxidation iron
oxide gives Mars this red color and can
be mixed with aluminum powder to form
firm but make sure that could be used to
weld together Mining rails thermite
melts right through metal and people in
seconds undergoing safety renovations
openings June 1991
it's an old coffee grinder shame it's
out of coffee this ol mine card is
covered in rust I could probably use
that hey what's this Oh
[Music]
I give and I give and I give and I give
and I give and you I don't even know if
anything was said about that by the
character she's moving on moving on
moving on is fine no that's not good oh
well now it's not a problem
easy breezy what is this oh my god I
hate it I hate this looks like a pretty
sturdy latch I'll need to think of
something clever maybe if I had a bobby
tuna I could pick it but something tells
me I won't find one down it a little bit
of hatchet
there's no I am cutting through this
with its current state after weaken the
locks I now have a duty work boot why
leave just one boot behind let's input
the picture from before did it only have
one leg I don't know I can only talk to
you from the past okay so that hole
thermite thing so we need iron oxide and
aluminum powder to get I need something
with a broader edge the all this rust
off here we go
scraped off as much rust as I can
reminds me of dad's car that's great
combine these two this Candy's to be in
a powdered form as well coffee grinder I
don't know if that org oh wow that's a
powerful coffee grinder I've grabbed the
cam is fun is possible oh yeah I'm
hoping I don't regret this ah you know
what's to regret nothing
carpe diem carpe diem here goes nothing
there's no way this is gonna work oh
well la he's definitely damaged this all
should be able to break it Kapow
my hat's it broke goddamn it but at
least a little lock is kinda or she'd
move freely all the way now all right
well then I'm sorry I'm frickin sorry
all right you know what I'm just gonna
go is it gonna go screw you here we go
I hate it oh I hate it I hate it I hate
caves
I hate dark scary caves I hate it it's
not a face I hate hey KACE all right
guys which way do you think I left
oh god no forward well hey hey wait a
minute
centre forward right oh I see it's a
series of you gotta make the right right
okay it's just gonna be trial and error
right center
nice no not nice I didn't get it
it started make logical sense for a cave
right left I'm guessing Center nope I
didn't get it let's try right left left
I bet they're trying to throw me off
dammit really I get the last one every
single time you're making me look that
dumb was that okay right left right
center left
I did it I'm the best difficult to
handle with one hand but heavy enough to
do some damage oh yeah I forgot my arm
is broken
ouchies looks like nobody has been here
in years yeah I think this is where the
sinkhole was oh if I had consulted the
map on Marty moles map sign it would
have been cleared it would have been
obvious God what is that some se pika
there's a card in the pocket I need to
leave likey to leave one is happen there
was this boys this goddamn loudest thing
oh I didn't even notice it oh my god the
seagull that close to my to trap the
miners I can't see the bottom
oh I believe you
wait I don't remember this oh god oh no
oh God oh no left center right left [ __ ]
[ __ ] how did I end up here I need to get
a button Oh
okay let me look at this map okay so
this was yeah right left right straight
left wait there's some other ventilation
shaft the ventilation shaft where's this
ventilation shaft there's a ventilation
shaft somewhere here bricks these bricks
looked less worn than the others I can
feel air being drowned through the gaps
aha well pickaxe take that bastard take
that oh I hate it I hate this butthole
oh he didn't hate the butthole Oh hate
the butthole Oh freedom freedom okay
this is good nope - mica mica mica come
on there we go there we go there we go
yeah yeah yeah yeah oh yeah oh that's
the good stuff let's get that clear this
bill away a little bit clear this some I
can clear now okay it's fine getting it
an idea for genius new multi-tool yeah
yeah yeah sassy
can I leave oh I can get out okay that's
fine huh the force feels darker somehow
huh how about that
who's gonna check to see if anything's
changed at the top of this okay I'm out
here around I'm gonna do thing I gotta
go do thing alright see ya hey I'm going
in here now uh okay good great let me
look at the call sign and book again
great okay
what happened that what happened that
there's a lot of problems here you heard
the door alone I didn't not exactly a
flare but I think you can work
okay that's great I hate this for God's
sake Josh you're gonna fix this and it's
coming out of you all your wages I got
it you second and I saved the park
fifteen bucks and I need to thank me I
left some instructions for who we should
call when we need help I copied them
down exactly from one of the new book
Josh what the hell did you do with the
emergency call science book for the
radio death and dismemberment callsign
tuned to the frequency to the mark
number I circled it in red pen after
taking apart the case hopefully I put
everything back where I sit the call
signed to our closest watchtower
Logan Watchtower flip the switch after
you've done this you just shoot the
flare by the highway and someone will be
there faster than you can say I stopped
the bleeding okay I gotta go look up the
code for Logan Watchtower Logan watched
it's not in here where's he disassembled
the radio maybe inside there I mean can
she come to try to dissemble this bad
boy not sure I'll be able to put this
back together if I took it apart okay so
guide for callsign information I know
this isn't quite right I should try
again I know I don't know what Logan
watched terrorists wnp let me try one of
the other ones though maybe they can
tell me W and P no oh I see aha so I
gotta go find this callsign wherever it
is I don't know where it would be but I
I got I got I gotta go find it I don't
know where it would be Oh
obviously I can just figure it out by
myself these are all just acronyms it's
Logan Watchtower it's LWT well W T its
markiplier actually okay yeah okay that
should do it I should get to the highway
and light a signal okay good my god blow
the picture
was it the tire was it the same okay so
that thing's here somewhere anywhere I'm
gonna just I'm I just booked it how
about I just run hub I'm gonna run hey
I'm just gonna go run hey how about that
I'm gonna go well no please no that's my
only way out I need a distraction
a loud noise near the highway yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah man yeah I like my
fingers I should put it on a hard flat
surface okay yeah man yeah yeah yeah
okay and what I'm gonna get out of here
okay I'm good right what happens if I
stick around I'm just curious I can't go
back that thing will be there okay yeah
you know you don't know that okay I'm
flare roman candle oh okay
monka lost a finger like that I should
find somewhere to play this oh you big
baby it's a real ego that should hold it
in place
okay this is it my ass quiet
please anyone okay it's really cold here
maybe I should get closer to the fire
members to shoot him in me maybe I
should lay my oh oh oh absolutely not
yeah you almost hit me with your car you
in fact I think you did hit me with your
car I'm going to sue you what a word
hand mouth creature that was I liked it
I liked it a lot too I sue boys studios
Graham Hutchinson Evan froze quite
spoopy maximum spewpa CH engaged is good
that's good that's very good I like that
a lot
I love a good point and click adventure
game I do I really do in this day and
age where graphics are whatever and ray
tracing is Yatta Yatta I love me a good
just plain old point-and-click Fisher
it's fun and that wasn't just a plain
old one that had a lot of little like
nuances it I loved it loved it oh oh
that should be back in a minute
well you know what I'm good for now
looks like Wendy Oakes is closing the
paper talks about disappearances and the
mysterious Vandal Oh
might have been me dad did this in one
of his classes he's really proud of it
the sun's almost up looks like the
weather's clearing up - it's been a hell
of a week the unknown suspect is wanted
for breaking and entering tampering with
evidence
property damage illegal use of fireworks
littering well you know how it goes
you know how it is you know how it be oh
hey Dad oh hi dad
Oh
oh that's just a little nice thing I
thought something horrible is gonna
happen
I was totally ready for something or
horrible to happen but hey that's pretty
good
I like that a lot that was shiver thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below if you got spooked if you
enjoyed it as much as I did in the
school [ __ ] territory
let me know down in the comments below
thank you everybody so much for watching
if you want more scary games there are
hundreds hundreds hundreds of them in
the playlist linked in the description
or in the suggestion right over there
check them out for yourself and stay
tuned for even more spooky horror themed
things coming at you hard and fast
thanks again and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]